la police arrive à ces monstres pour que vous
vous pouvez imaginer que c'est complètement différent
les gens sont une chose quand ils sont assis sur Internet et
un rambo si cool pousse une fille
certains ou un enfant du toit pour sauter et
il y construit tout un concept
sous la conduite dès que la police
Je suis entré dans mon pantalon, mettez-le au sens littéral
de ce mot, quel genre de bâtard va s'asseoir là
tu comprends le coup de coeur des insectes ce n'est pas dommage
pousse les filles garçons à se suicider
Et
et en même temps aligner le travail comme ça
d'une manière que je gagne aussi de l'argent sur ce
à quoi ça sert de gagner de l'argent dessus
les annonces sont placées autre chose à faire
quelque chose qui est tout ici, nous ne pouvons pas
ne laisse personne le faire